sara is with us in atlanta hi Sarah
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi mr. MC how are you today better than
I deserve what's up I have a question I
am 23 years old and I am a new listener
I actually started listening about a
year ago and about a month before I
found you I bought a brand new car so I
that is my only debt my income I have
two jobs right now
one is a like a 280 a week my second one
is a waitress so it changes it's 250 to
300 a week I'm wondering in my position
I've got 18,000 miles on the car and I'm
wondering if I should fill it now being
that I've already lost the money or just
buckle down being that that's not only
dead and get rid of it okay so your
take-home pay is somewhere in the
neighborhood of $2,000 a month
correct yes sir okay and how much is the
car payment it's about 360 Wow I I send
in about 400 and week I'm sorry for
every month yeah and how much do you owe
on the car about probably I'm going to
say 26 just to be safe 26,000 yes sir
okay and you know you barely make 26,000
a year
yes well well when I bought the car I
was actually I was in a different work
situation and I was working for my
family and the business actually went
under and I was a big pay cut which I'm
making it work but I just didn't know
how much I was going to lose if I tried
to fill it now and start over kind of
things
well the question of the way I look at
it is not how much you're going to lose
the question I look at is which path
keeping the car or selling the car puts
you in the best place 3 5 10 years from
now
okay okay and when you were making 26
r20 yeah around 26 $27,000 a year and
you know $26,000 on your car
there's no path that that that's going
to make that make sense the only thought
that would make that make sense as if
you have you know a job offer next week
for your income to double alright and
then it may be sorta starts to make
sense but your income would have to
double almost immediately and I you know
I didn't hear anything this conversation
telling me that do you know that that's
going to happen this is early no sir not
anytime soon
then you need to sell the car okay
that's what I thought but I was not
wanting to I don't blame you but do you
see why it's just you have this huge
white around your neck I did yeah right
I mean it's a massive debt based on your
income your current income where you are
today and really it was a bad decision
but what happened was like you said you
were working in a different situation
before and then when you lost your job
and got this new job and a part-time job
you know the lack of income reveals how
bad a decision it was before you can
kind of hide it because you were making
more money in a sense you're hiding it
in the math that kind of stuff so there
you go that's what I would do
hey thanks for the call this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]